welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel studios eternals finally
gives us an official first look of its
massive cast and hints at a deepened mcu
mythology
all of which we must derive from 14
seconds within a marvel sizzle cut
without getting too distracted by this
remarkably cut
sizzle i mean who needs sunglasses when
you're hotter than the sun right i'm
thinking he's the reason the sun has to
wear sunglasses sometimes
look there is plenty to talk about from
this limited footage like who everyone
is how the eternals will redefine the
broader mcu
and interesting visual details hidden in
the background of these shots that blow
this mystery plot wide open so roll that
clip
when you love something you fight for it
[Music]
we're the ones who changed everything
okay so the eternals are a group of
ageless godlike protectors hidden on
earth since ancient times they include
gemma chan
as cersei who can manipulate matter and
has an affinity for humankind
including her love interest played by
kit harington the human dane whitman aka
marvel's black knight wielder of the
ebony blade now
jimmy chan previously played the cree
minerva in captain marvel leading the
eternals is richard madden as icarus
their military commander is angelina
jolie as thina who can form any weapon
out of cosmic energy
at her side as dawn lee as gilgamesh the
strongest
eternal who can project an exoskeleton
of cosmic energy brian tyree henry
espastos
a super smart inventor eternal who's
been helping human technology advance
he will be the first mcu hero to be
depicted as gay which
cool but why didn't it drink that long
camel nanjiani is kingo
a fame hungry eternal who becomes a
bollywood film star
lauren ridloff is makari who uses super
speed to scout planets
ridloff is a deaf actress and makari
will be the first deaf mcu superhero
with her deafness
actually making her unaffected by her
own sonic booms liam mchugh
is sprite who appears as a 12 year old
but is as ancient as the others
she can project lifelike illusions barry
kogan is druid
the bad boy who can control the minds of
others
and he withdraws from the other eternals
out of a disagreement with their
relationship with mankind and apparently
over the years this whole group has
separated in this kind of exile
drug likely opposes cersei's love for
dane whitman as well as the aid given to
humans by fastos
and sama hayek as ajak the spiritual
leader and healer of the eternals who
has helped advance human civilization in
other ways
perhaps the advanced healing technology
used by groups like the wakandans
she can communicate with the celestials
now the celestials are the gigantic
armored space gods of the marvel
universe whom we have seen in concept
art showing ereshem
nazar the calculator hargen and jemiah
in guardians of the galaxy the collector
tanelli tavon told us about the ancient
celestial issan the searcher who once
wielded the power stone
and nowhere was the severed head of a
celestial and in guardians vol 2 peter
quill's biological father ego
is a celestial taking human and
planetary form now the celestials
created the eternals as
protectors against groups like the
deviants and part of this creation
mythology is also
humankind and mutant kind making many
believe the eternals film could explain
the origin of the
x gene in the mcu perhaps something
wanda maximoff could have been born with
and prior to wanda's infinity stone
supercharge allowed her to be able to
cast low-level probability hexes now i
should point out that our boy thanos is
also an eternal carrying the deviant
gene
born on the planet titan according to
thanos comics creator jim starlin
this eternal's film is expected to go
into young thanos's connection to this
ancient backstory but this footage shows
some western imagery from chloe zhao who
just won an oscar for directing nomad
land
and here depicts ajax riding a horse
with her voice saying when you love
something you fight for it cersei's love
for dane is at the heart of this story
and it may spark a conflict among the
eternals who are currently scattered in
exile
between human-loving eternals like
cersei ajack and fostos
and ones who would rather just control
them like drink much of this is actually
based in greek mythology in which the
gods have varying personalities like
this and disagree
over how much to intervene with human
events in matters like war
politics even love but this eternal's
film is also drawing on mythology from
across the globe while icarus nina and
cersei's names are rooted in greek
mythology gilgamesh's name comes from
the hero of mesopotamian
mythology a beautiful beach shot shows
what looks like sprite and cersei
holding hands surrounded by fastos
thena makari and drig now in the comics
sprite
wipes the eternal's memories so that
they forget their ancient past
we could be seeing that here with the
sunset symbolizing the sun
setting on their shared memories as they
go their separate ways
that memory loss could also explain why
the eternals haven't interfered in past
avengers conflicts like with their
memories wiped they didn't fully yet
appreciate their roles but if that's the
case
what triggered the awakening from that
slumber now
the power of love between cersei and
dane
nah that sounds lame going by everything
else in phase four i'm guessing that
they're just gonna blame it all on end
game
the arrival of that dreaded eternal with
that dreaded deviant gene
thanos but more importantly the cosmic
energy radiated from the stones on his
fist
which could be the original source of
the eternal's powers because along with
east on the search who wielded the power
stone
nebula gave us another link between the
celestials and the infinity stones
calling the soul stones resting place
minion of death at the very center of
celestial existence
so in the way that one division pointed
to the cosmic radiation wanda inherited
from the mind stone as the cmbr of the
west few hex
and what supercharged monica rambo the
same mind stone that alerted vision
of his coming doom in infinity war that
could be the same radiation that
originally powered
and four snaps later reawakens these
eternals but before i continue thanks to
trade coffee for sponsoring this video
i love cold brew coffee it's a great
warm weather treat but it can get pricey
pretty quickly
trade gives you next level cold brew
coffee at home for as low
as one dollar per cup trade has these
new cold brew kits that are a one-stop
shop to make cold brew at home
sign up to receive freshly roasted cold
brew coffee along with easy to use
brewing bags
set your delivery schedule flavor
preference grind and bag size before you
get started it's a no risk trial if you
don't love your first coffee trade will
replace it for free
no mess no measurement no equipment
needed with trade specially designed
cold brew bags
these bags and the red bags they use for
delivery are all compostable new
rockstars viewers get 50
off their first bag when they sign up
offer valid for the first 100 people who
click the link in the description so
click that link in the description box
and enter code rockstars 50
free shipping is also included and again
thanks to trade coffee for sponsoring
but really the most interesting shot
shows can go sprite cersei icarus thena
and gilgamesh in this forest
village behind them are some creepy
looking children of the corn
[ __ ]
in matching overalls yeah matching
overalls better check their shoes for
matching black and white nikes
one theory is that this cult could be
mind controlled by druid like his
idyllic utopia formed as he believes
humanity
should live in a state of nature cut off
from the corrupt
technological advancements fastos has
given human culture
where every surface in the mcu is a blue
translucent hollow screen and everything
else is a barf projection but notice how
behind kingo is a
camera crew much like how in that other
shot of him there's an assistant
following him around with a smaller
camera
as a big-time bollywood actor he may
have a documentary group following him
around though that would conflict with
the eternal soul mission of secrecy
so perhaps their reunion with each other
here is part of a public coming out
campaign
or maybe it's a documentary crew looking
at this cult in the woods then a shot in
this dark
burning forest where athena swings her
cosmic sword against some other
combatant so you can see the energy of
her blade weaving together as she poses
with it it is a bit too dark to
determine who she is sword fighting with
but if you brighten up the shot you can
see this is actually gilgamesh here
so maybe a division in the ranks between
these two warriors
next makari zips in besides thena
gilgamesh icarus and kango before the
walls of this ancient city this is the
famous ishtar gate from the city of
babylon
now a museum attraction in real life but
here it looks like it's been
reconstructed in its original form
from 575 bce those animals show
alternating rows of dragons balls and
lions symbolizing the gods marduk adad
and ishtar it's pretty cool to see the
eternals fighting battles on
actual original wonders of the world
before they were considered historical
wonders
similar to the way loki is using a
marvel god to explain historical
mysteries like demi cooper in pompeii
to the right is the wreckage of some
kind of vehicle it's hard to tell if
it's an ancient one or like an advanced
craft either way there could be some
kind of advanced cosmic interference
that led to this structure ending up in
a museum
by the way you know what killmonger
would say about this museum's equal
colonization but i'll save that for my
indiana jones spec script where short
round puts back everything in d
dug up it's gonna be good but then
cersei says
we're the ones who changed everything
reflecting how all the fantastical
quirks of the mcu from the androids the
aliens and the wizards are all about to
get rooted in the same genetic history
to which the eternals were the key they
were the ones who set earth on this
alternate trajectory from our own real
world instead a world where those early
technological advancements enjoyed by
people like the starks or the wakandans
were all
rooted in gifts from above oh and
speaking of gifts new rockstars has all
kinds of great gift options available in
our merch store
like this old dumb shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com but all kinds of
other great designs and thanks again to
trade coffee for sponsoring this video
click the link in the description and
use the code rockstars50 for 50
off your first bag follow me on
instagram and twitter eaboss follow new
rockstars and subscribe to rockstars for
breakdowns
of everything marvel thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you